So what we can do is to apply V dagger to whatever state we
obtained from our circuit.
And then if we perform a
standard basis measurement, we'll get the number Y
that we're looking for, expressed as a string
of length two in binary.
Before we go any further, let's talk a bit more
about the unitary matrix V.
This is a special matrix and
you may have seen it before.
It's the matrix associated
with a linear operation on four dimensional vectors known as the discrete Fourier transform.
To be more precise, the discrete Fourier transform can be defined for any
positive integer dimension, and we'll take a look at it
in general in a few moments.
And this is what it
looks like specifically when the dimension is equal to four.
We can think about the
discrete Fourier transform in different ways.
We can think about it purely abstractly as a linear mapping on vectors that can be represented by a matrix.
And we can also think about
it as a computational problem where we're given a vector, and we want to compute the result
of applying this linear mapping.
That turns out to be an incredibly important
computational problem, and there's a highly efficient algorithm for performing that computation
known as the fasts Fourier transform.
In fact, this is such an important problem in signal processing for example, that the fasts Fourier
transform is considered by many
to be one of the most important and consequential
algorithms ever discovered.
We can also think about the
discrete Fourier transform as a unitary quantum operation that can be applied to
a quantum state vector.
And when we think about it in that way, we call it the quantum Fourier
transform, or QFT for short.
Mathematically speaking, it's essentially the same thing as the discrete Fourier transform, but we call it the
quantum Fourier transform
just to clarify that it's an operation being applied to a quantum state vector.
So let's change the name of our matrix, from V to QFT four to reflect the fact
that the operation that we've come up with is in fact the quantum Fourier transform.
So here's the complete circuit for learning the value of Y when we're promised that
theta equals Y over four
for Y being zero, one, two, or three.
And just to make sure it's clear, we're applying the inverse of
the quantum Fourier transform, or in other words QFT four dagger
to map one of the four possible states back to the standard basis state, cat Y, so that we can recover Y by measuring.
So that's the circuit we
get from thinking about the promised version of the
phase estimation problem, where we're promised that theta
is zero, one quarter, one
half, or three quarters, but there's nothing that prevents us
from running this circuit for
an arbitrary value of theta.
And if we do that, here
are the probabilities for the four possible
outcomes that we obtain.
Each of the four possible
values for Y has its own color, and the plot tells us
what the probabilities are for each one as a function of theta.
So for instance, if theta
is equal to three quarters, we'll get the outcome
three with probability one,
well the probabilities for the other three outcomes are all zero as we already know from thinking about the promise version of the problem.
If theta is close to three quarters but not exactly three quarters, there will be some non-zero probability associated with the other outcomes,
but we'll still get the outcome
three with high probability.
So even though theta may
not be equal to Y over four, we can still think
about the outcome we get from the measurements divided by four
as being a guess or an
approximation for theta.
The guess may be wrong, but nevertheless it is
providing us with information.
And one thing that we
can learn from the plot is that best approximations always have the highest
probabilities associated with them.
When I say best approximation, I mean whatever value of Y over four is closest to the true value of theta,
in the modular one sense. The worst possible case is that theta is exactly halfway between
two values of Y over four.
For example, if theta is equal
to three eighths or 0.375, in this case we see
that the approximations
one quarter and two quarters
or one half are equally good.
So in this particular
case there are actually two best approximations rather than one.
And we're equally likely to get the outcome one
and the outcome two.
The other two outcomes zero and three, which don't give very good
approximations to theta when we divide by four, actually do appear with some probability
which appears to be just
under 10% in both cases.
So this procedure isn't perfect, but it does provide us with information.
And it's noteworthy that
regardless of theta, we're always guaranteed to draw either the best approximation
or one of the two best approximations when there's a tie, with probability that
appears to be just above 40%.